but as you know we generally for this
work and kind of randomized the topics
of the tools but in a you know master
stager scheduling and we do actually
have two tips that are closely related
effect that tell us about complementary
is officer invested forever yeah if you
think I like sit out there and thank you
for inviting me to come and speak here
so what I'm going to talk about is the
compliment
- yawns talk the in approximability of
the independence at polynomial in the
complex plane funnily enough my
introduction is going to be very closely
aligned to yawns I'm going to run
through it quite quickly but they might
have some people in the audience who
didn't come for his talk so I'll go
through it anyway so we are given a
graph G and an independent set is a set
of vertices but we have no edges between
them so this is an example of an
independent set of size three and it is
a very well-known and key hard to find a
largest independent set so what people
have looked at as a complimentary way of
looking at the problem is what if we
don't try to go for the optimization
problem what if we don't try to find the
largest one but what if you look at all
of them okay finding a small independent
set namely the empty one will be do half
don't have any vertices is an easy
problem but problem is that the all of
the independent set there can be up to
two to the n of them so exponentially
many which from computer science
perspective is a little bit of a problem
because we don't have that time to
enumerate or independent sets well and
then there's yet another version of the
problem and that is a weighted counting
of all independent sets so now we have a
certain parameter which will be one
doubt and we'll call activity and what
it does it kind of gives us a way of
fine-tuning whether we want to go for
small independent sets or large
independent sets so if lambda is bigger
than one
we are going to give well for anyone
that we are going to give the weight of
lambda to the number of vertices in my
independent set that's going to be the
weight for this independent set and so
if you want a speaker than one we're
kind of giving water weight to the large
enough an ascetic is smaller than one
you're giving weight to the small ones
and this brings us to the independence
at polynomial so the independent set
polynomial is simply sum of all of these
weights and I worked it out and I think
this is the independent set polynomial
for my little toy graph that I'm showing
you
and as Yun mentioned this is related to
the partition function of the hard core
model of gas from statistical physics
I'm not going to repeat with the hard
core model is but it's it's a studied
quantity when we are positive Wanda
positive real Wanda and yen also
mentioned that feces are actually been
looking at negative values so what is
our problem statement given a graph
lambda we want to compute the value of
the independent set polynomial for this
specific land okay and that's what's
called the partition function as well
though I will start to stay away from
that because I think it's mostly used
for lambdas being from the real world
okay so there are some exact computation
results namely for some special day of
classes like bounded tree with graphs we
can compute this value exactly it's not
surprising it's useful in some scenarios
but it's not very surprising however
dating back to 1979 the original
introduction of the salt also called
sharpy class of counting problems
Valiants showed that it's actually
sharpie hard to evaluate independence at
polynomial for lambda equal to 1 which
corresponds to counting all independent
set and so this from computational
perspective tells us that it seems very
unlikely that we will be able to design
a polynomial time algorithm that
computes the number of
in abundance at nobody and then bullet
oh brother and chi-chan a new extended
this sharpie hardness result for any
complex lambda trying to get the full
classification so this is exact
computation and we want to compute the
value of the dependence that polynomial
Atlanta exactly so we have hardness
seems unlikely so let's move to
approximation so approximation and we're
going to restrict ourselves to graphs
with bounded degree we're going to use
capital Delta as the band on our maximum
degree we know that exact computation
was difficult for the bounce three even
for three regular graphs when my graph
had every vertex has three neighbors it
was already hard to compute the
independence that polynomial exactly so
this brings us to this notion of f
pecans for the polynomial time
approximation scheme and what it is is
that we get I am phrasing here for the
specific problem of computing the
independence of polynomial so I'm given
my input which in my case is the graph G
and lambda but I also have a kind of
error epsilon and what I want I want to
compute a value that is within 1 plus
minus epsilon factor of the independent
set polynomial evaluated at lambda but I
want to be able to compute this value in
polynomial time
just polynomial on the size of the input
okay and so now this picture is coming
here is going to look eerily similar
jion's these are exactly the same result
that he mentioned so we have a critical
threshold and lower bites back in 2006
showed that we have an FPT us in the
regime for lambda
up to this critical threshold that
depends on the maximum degree of my
graph a beautiful is out based on
correlation decay which was then
followed by a series of work starting
with a very nice result by a landslide
then continuing with two other follow-up
works that show that it is np-hard to
approximate the independence of
polynomial beyond this critical
threshold by the way I am staying within
the realm of deterministic algorithms
there are also some randomized
algorithms over here but I'm just not
going to mention them now and then
Andres Galan is Wesley Goldberg and then
your safe Anchorage oh I should have
mentioned I wanted to highlight
MacArthur's so this is joint work with
Andres Galan ease of Oxford Lesley
Goldberg is sitting right here also
Oxford and they just are encouraged and
so the three of them did prove NP
hardness of approximation up to this
shear threshold quantity which depends
again on the maximum degree in my graph
it's really minus this quantity and this
is very very nice this out and that
brings us to a little deep tour of the
lavas local Emma I'm actually not going
to go through this because yan did such
a wonderful job talking about the lavas
local Emma so the bottom line okay this
is a little bit much cruder description
of yawns but the point is that Louis
local emma is connected to computation
of independence at polynomials even for
negative and possibly even for complex
lambdas through the work of Scott and so
Hall as year okay so for the motivation
we want to compute independence of
polynomial values for lambdas even in
the negative regime but also for complex
values and so that brings us to the ants
beautiful talk where he was talking
about an F key cos within this little
circle around that extends all the way
to the shear threshold bound and that's
the radius of the circle and then we
have also a nasty toss using what was it
Barbie knock philosophy
become very nicely South by battling
ghost X over here who also can handle
exactly the same circle now Peters and
ghost rights have this small rectangle
around the positive real line all the
way to the threshold critical threshold
and after that they also in the very
same paper identify this cardioid region
which is a region where certain
references converge certain univariate
references converge I'll talk a little
bit about that in a second
but somehow the original intuition was
that maybe maybe we could have
polynomial time approximation algorithms
for lambdas drawn from this cardioid
shape and not outside okay now my
picture is stuck in 2018 we saw an
updated picture so there's one other
thing that is happening in 2018 okay
this is a very very crude picture
because I am using PowerPoint and I
apologize to bench and Shikari
this is really not what it should look
like look at the on slides or their
paper it's the poster kind of a like
this but they identified a region where
the independence of polynomial doesn't
have any zeros and then from that it
follows that they said an F PETA's in
that region so the part that is missing
here are the little points by boys
am i pronouncing it right nice okay
those the little points over here little
andas for which the independence of
polynomial has zeros and the lambda is
within the cardioid region and also
these kind of green little nice region
that
and here Srivastava did just very
recently as of last week ago okay so
this is the picture and our the video
well we do the outside so the outside is
we are going to show that it is sharpie
hard to approximate our independence a
polynomial outside of this cardioid
region and in particular we are going to
show that it's short be hard to
approximate either its norm or its angle
I'm going to be focusing on the norm
it's very similar pouch okay so now
what's going on so would be one let me
go back so we are going to draw lambda
anywhere outside of our cardioid and we
want to evaluate and we are also given a
graph and we want to evaluate meaning
approximate the norm of the independence
of polynomial for this one right that's
the setup Wow except what we're going to
do let's for starters actually explain
ourselves to the multivariate setting
what does that mean before every vertex
was equal every vertex if it was in the
independent set in her contribution
lambda okay now let's give a different
activity to every vertex and so we are
going to do exactly the same thing but
now for a given independence that we are
going to take product of the lambda and
we claim that is shortly hard to
approximate the norm of the multivariate
independence a polynomial and how does
it work and so what we are going to do
we are going to pretend that we can
approximate this norm and then from then
you're going to conclude that we would
be able to solve the problem of
computing the number of in the
in a given graph exactly which we know
is a hard problem which means that our
problem has to be hard as well okay so
here's a picture this is the graph age
that we are given for which we want to
compute the number of independent set
okay we are going to transform it into a
graph G by adding a new vertex
connecting it to everybody else and
setting the activity at this vertex so
this is a minus 2 minus some value and
all of the other vertices are going to
have activity 1 okay so now what happens
if we try to compute the multivariate
independence a polynomial for this graph
where we are going to approximate this
multivariate independent set polynomial
but what is it well are they this new
vertex is in the independent set in
which case nobody else can be in the set
and therefore the weight of that set is
minus M or the vertex is not there in
which case we have exactly the original
independent sets in our original graph
ok so we are really estimating the
absolute value of these two numbers so
we are going to go for we are going to
try to find M such that this quantity is
equal to 0 which will let me output
exactly the number of independent sets
in the original graph ok now I don't
know which end to start with I know the
number of independent sets can be
anywhere between 1 & 2 to the N so it
sounds like some kind of a binary search
fine but we have to be just a little bit
more careful so here is here several
points that we need to address the first
thing is the binary search on M I just
have a little picture here so M ranges
anywhere between two to the N and 0 and
this quantity is an absolute value so we
have to be a little bit more careful
with binary search we cannot just look
in the middle because we don't know
whether we can eliminate
laughs tonight we have to evaluate
approximate our independence at
polynomial at several values but a
constant number and based on that we can
eliminate some part of the range of M
okay so that the small technicality now
the next thing to notice is I didn't
really highlight it let me go back to
the theorem there is the theorem here it
is sharpie hard to approximate the
independence at polynomial so I'm
assuming that I fixed my maximum degree
okay so I have a fixed Delta because my
cardioid region depends on the maximum
degree okay but what did I do with this
reduction I suddenly introduced a vertex
that has a very large degree so I need
to then well deal with it and so that
brings us to this degree deducing gadget
so what this one so we can come up with
a graph it has two vertices of degree
one that has the effect of when u and V
are of opposite membership in an
independent set so U is in an
independent certainly is not or vice
versa the independent set polynomial
restricted to such independent sets is
going to evaluate to 0 so this gadget
essentially has the effect of forcing U
and V to be either both in or both out
so it's doing an equality I'm not going
to go into the details here this is this
is just a kind of remark on the side
that it is it is not difficult to deal
with the large degree vertex that we
introduced okay and it turns out that
this gadget for us is just going to be a
simple path where we carefully select
the activities possible and something
like five but we carefully select the
activities at
these vertices just saw that the
contribution of U and B evens out to
zero if u is in and B is out and vice
versa
okay and so then when we have a graph of
a larger degree we can just split the
vertex of a larger degree into multiple
vertices connect them with a gadget that
and forces that these two endpoints up
to the other both in or both out and we
reduce the degree okay
likewise oh sorry likewise we can do the
same thing to convert our graph into a
bipartite graph there is a bipartite
nice gadget again just a path so the
only thing that we need to really worry
about is that here we extended ourselves
to the multi variate setting where we
allowing activities to be well 1 or
minus m or we can this gadget there are
a couple of other values but what we
really have is just lambda you're
proving that it's hard to evaluate the
independence of polynomial for one
specific complex valued lambda outside
of the cardioid so what we need to do we
need to somehow take our lambda and
convert it to simulate other activities
so that's the setup that we are at right
now okay and so what I thought I just
really did again what was the point
about by politeness oh it was just a
stronger theorem that is actually an
sharpie hard to compute the approximate
independent set polynomial even for
bipartite graphs of bounded degrees okay
so now this is the set up we needed
different activities but we are given
only lambda so we're going to play with
our lambda and somehow we're going to
modify this graph so that it behaves as
if it had the activities that I want
namely 1 and minus and
okay and so what does that mean that
means to be going to do another gadget
earring we're going to attach a gadget
to every vertex and it's going to be
this blue thingies and each of these
gadgets is going to be responsible for
having the effect of the vertex that is
attaching to having the desired activity
okay and it turns out but then what we
want for the gadget is if we have a
target activity under prime so let's say
- end okay so once we attach these
gadgets all these gadgets will have only
lambdas in them and these - human ones
will not be there anymore the caches
will be acting as if it was activity -
ever one so we take our target activity
lambda prime and we're going to create a
graph gadget where we have one special
vertex B the vertex that we are going to
use to attach to and then that has
degree 1 because we are going to be
attaching the gadget we are going to
increase the degree so we don't want to
have very large degree of this vertex
all of the other vertices here are going
to have bounded degree by our Delta the
band that we have on the degree and we
will want the contribution of the
independent set polynomial when this
vertex is in the set I'm using this
notation G comma V equal to 1 being
equal to 1 means that I'm looking on the
independence at independence where V is
in so the contribution of dogs
independent sets over the contribution
of the independence that's when V is not
in I want this ratio to be equal to
roughly ideally equal to lambda Prime in
reality it's going to be very close to
on the prime
okay now the question is why well I just
took the definition from the bottom of
the slide up here so what is the effect
of attaching G to a vertex B well if I
have my original graph H and then I do
the attachment and I ducks p8 a new
graph H prime let's do a very quick
calculation so what is the independence
of polynomial for H prime now everybody
has activity on the lambda so the V
vertex is either in an independent set
or out if it is in it has to be in the
independent set for both H and G if it
is out it has to be out of the
independent set for both H and G and so
now let me just do a quick manipulation
namely when we divide both sides by the
quantity when we don't have B in the
sets when B is not present and we just
divide it nothing more and then we look
at what we get but what we get is the
contribution of the independence that
polynomial only in the graph h plus the
contribution of the independent set
polynomial only in the graph H 1 B is
equal to 1 this was B's if not in an
independent set this was V in an
independent set and then we have this
ratio which is really just our lambda
prime so the point being is that this
gadget is what we're looking for because
that has the effect of simulating lambda
Prime activity at the vertex V so now we
moved ourselves and what we are going to
do we are going to create this gadget
now if we also need to be a little bit
mindful about that it's a minor
technical the technicality is that the
target independent set polynomial the
one where we are pretending that we have
lambda prime is like the independence of
polynomial when we attach the graph but
there is this devising factor so we need
to be able to compute it so the
then we can adjust the quantity so it's
a small minor technicality we just need
to be able to compute this quantity
that's all I'm saying
okay okay so how are you going to create
this gadget so what we what do we want
we want a gadget where the ratio of the
contribution of the independence of
polynomial when my vertex B is in a set
over not in a set equals to some desired
target activity lambda prime okay and
well the simplest possible graph we
could try is a tree so let's write up
let's try to use a tree to construct our
and so the advantage of using a tree to
constructing this gathered is that we
can compute these quantities easily so
the issue from the previous slide is not
a problem if it's a tree it just we have
a nice preference and weaknesses compute
this and we can construct the tree
recursively and so how would that work
well if we already have some trees that
we constructed and these trees implement
different activities so let's say this
is activity lambda prime 4 3 T 1 lambda
prime foot 3 T 2 and so on and so forth
what can we do well we have all of these
extra vertices maybe we can just merge
so if we just merge them and create one
extra vertex at the top what is the new
activity well this is a small
computation I'm going to use D to be the
degree minus 1 so I'm going to be
merging degree minus 1 so that I have
still one extra degree left for my
vertex at all and so what I get is the
following
you can just exactly the same type of
computation that we had before we can
look at the contribution to the
independence a polynomial when this new
vertex V is in an independent set or if
it's out so if the new vertex is in what
is the contribution means that it is
getting a factor of 1 that and then it
means that all of these neighbors have
to be out so we are just taking a
product of the out options for the
smaller trees likewise we can do the
same type of computation for V equal to
0 and I'm not going to go through all
the details but it's not a difficult
type of computation but what it gives us
it gives us a certain type of reference
where we compute the new activity using
the old activities and well what's
Reaper amat right so that the records
looks beautiful or more beautiful so
we're going to divide the target
activity by lambda and then we are going
to get this reference so this is going
to be the records that we are going to
be working with today ok now looking
back what do we get out of this
reference well would be kind of one this
reference is we can compute these
quantities by building trees and so if
we start with some basic quantities
something that we can easily get by just
having what's a one vertex and then we
are going to keep merging these trees
and using these references we ultimately
want to get lambda prime if we get ok
the only thing I'm trying to say is that
when I look at this reference I will be
off by a factor of lambda and I just
have to adjust afterwards ok ok so now I
have the reference like this that I can
simulate by building a tree
are we good so what does this mean well
if I look at a complete be regular tree
then my smaller trees are all the same
which
the activities that they implement are
all the same which brings me to the
following univariate reference okay
and I can see okay so if I build my
gadget as a complete theory tree does it
give me anything well hopefully it will
converge somewhere to some fixed point
but there are some issues we need to
talk about first of all I don't have the
luxury of including an infinitely large
tree but it's a minor thing second thing
is is it even converging and the second
thing is even if it is converging I
really wanted some desired activity
along the prom and I'm getting some X
star okay
so there are some problems but let's
take a little complex detour first and
what we are going to work with if you
look back at our reference this is just
a rational map a polynomial divided by
polynomial in lambda so a little complex
detour when I have a reference that can
be written as a rational map okay then I
can talk about its fixed point which is
well I can do it any way but in this
case I will be talking about rational
map fixed points so a fixed point when
the value equals to the function value
but for rational Maps this is just a
root of a polynomial because I just take
my Q Z animal person by Z star and I
want to get P okay okay and then we have
this concept of a multiplier at a fixed
point which is just the derivative at
that fixed point and we say that a fixed
point is attracting if the norm of the
multiplier is smaller than one it's
depending if it's bigger than one and
neutral if it's equal to one and then we
are going to use some theory of complex
dynamics so this is an option of a patio
set which is intuitively point let's
start together walk together
so what it means is that a point in the
Fatu sudsy 0 for any foolish length
right so they're going to have a leash
between them for any leash length
epsilon there exists Delta such that if
I start with somebody closer than Delta
to me and then as I apply my map the
point will always stay with an episode
of each other so they're going to be on
an absent leash okay it's a very
interesting concept a new thing to me
before this work but the thing that we
are really interested in is the
complement of the fatu set the so-called
Julia set and it oh there okay this was
supposed to be higher up the repelling
fixed points are in the Julia set okay
okay so now the last bit of this is so
now it turns out there's a theorem in
the theory of complex dynamics that
tells us that if you take any point in
the Julia set and some neighborhood
around it and then we apply our map to
this neighborhood we will cover the
entire complex plane the exception of
something called exceptional set but
let's not worry about that doesn't it
apply in our case so the way to
visualize this is the repelling well if
my element in the Julia set is a
repelling fixed point it can imagine it
as a fan and then this neighborhood that
you have you can imagine it as a tomato
that you're throwing at the fan and if
you do that so what happens you have the
whole room covered okay so it's
something like that okay so now you're
going to use this how well first of all
going back to the work of panel index we
can notice that for lambda
inside the cardioid there exists it for
the univariate
math that I put here for your
convenience there exists an attractive
fixed-point a unique attractive fixed
point but for lambda outside of the
cardioid which is our pace all the fixed
points are repelling okay so what
happens next
well next what do we want we want to
implement some target activity the minus
M ideally but we are given along that
somewhere in the complex plane
we know the rational map is simulated by
a D regular tree because that's how we
got our reference for the map and so the
new game plan that we have is we are
going to get close to a repelling fixed
point throwing the tomato at it and then
use the tomato Julius a theorem to cover
the entire complex plane and get
anywhere toward desired lambda prime
okay
so now there are some issues to address
here with the game plan so what do we
have now so we know we have our
fractional math we are outside of the
cardioid and all fixed points are
repelling so we kind of want to get
close to the public fixed point but you
know it's kind of hard because it's
repelling so what do we do well let's go
back to the multi variant map in the
multivariate map we didn't connect trees
that were all equal we connected
different trees that implemented
different activities okay does that
possibly help well let's see so this was
the univariate map this is the
multivariate method of including for
your convenience and what we are going
to do we are going to create our trees
in a fibonacci like way okay so namely
or if you want you can look at this
constructing the the X quantities in our
multivariate map
okay so we start with some base cases so
our initial little trees are just little
trees or X's corresponding to one and
what happens next the next tree we are
going to compute or the next map we are
going to compute from the last de
quantities be computed okay so I try I
try to do a picture here so this is when
we are first merging all the little
trees into one so this is our D plus 1
case ok and now we are going to take
this tree that we have and three little
ones and it looks like this and then we
are going to take this tree the previous
tree and two little ones and it's going
to look like this you have no idea how
difficult just draw okay
and then like this okay I stopped here
so then since the Fibonacci tree like
construction the question is is it any
good well I guess the intuition for this
comes from when we look at the
multivariate map and we fix we fix D -
one of the parameters and then we have
only one parameter to play with suddenly
it becomes a contracting map in certain
regions so I think that would be my
intuition for why this should work but
let's just go through a little
calculation and I'm going to show you
that it actually has the effect of
converging to the repulsive fixed point
of the univariate map so I'm using this
multivariate map to get to the repulsive
fixed point of the univariate map and
namely I'm going to get to the one with
the smallest known we can show that all
the fixed points have different norms
okay so this is just the recap of the
construction and now let's see what
happens let's look at the following
polynomials so
who said my first D was one polynomials
to just one so a constant polynomial but
the next polynomial I'm going to take by
taking the previous polynomial plus
lambda times the BF polynomial from the
end so where am I going with this well
it turns out that if I build by
polynomials this way they represent
independent set polynomials of the
following graph
I think vertices from the plus 1 all the
way to the K that I'm currently at and
now I claim that PK the case polynomial
is the independent set of this graph and
this is not difficult to see by
induction because when I add a new paper
spurs vertex well if it is in an
independent set it's going to have a
contribution of lambda and then it's
going to peel all of its previous D
neighbors so then I will have to
multiply by P of K minus D on the other
hand if my new vertex is not in the
independent set then I'm free to take
any independent sets from the previous K
so now what's going on well this graph
has one other neat feature namely it is
claw free it doesn't contain this type
of a clogger as an indian sub graph and
to those customers out there for claw
free graphs independence a polynomial
has only real roots ok so what I'm going
to do now I'm actually going to restrict
ourselves to our lambda activity being
given as a complex number where has some
complex part okay and in such cases so
I'm going to I'm going to work on this
is the harder case so I'm going to
assume that my lambda is somewhere in
the complex plane not on the real line
so then these polynomials have only real
roots which means that for my land
this is a nonzero quantity and I can
divide by it so what I can now do I can
set up a new variable which is simply a
ratio of these two polynomials
piqué and piqué plus 1 and I do a little
calculation and I actually noticed that
the like a recurrence is exactly equal
to my multi-variant reference so from
that it follows and my YK quantity is
the same as XK which means my xk czardas
ratio of these two polynomials it's a
little bit like magic and I don't really
have any good intuition for why it works
but it does okay so what happens next
well so now we are not really looking at
polynomials let's look at it as a
reference and it's people not sheet type
like records okay we are computing a new
quantity from the previous quantities
and so we can apply the theory of linear
references and we can just do the
characteristic polynomial look at its
roots and then the KL term just like
when we are doing a closed form
expression for the Fibonacci number it's
a linear combination of the reciprocals
of the roots of the characteristic
polynomial the same kind of thing
happens here and so what we get is that
our quantity XK from our map from our
fibonacci like map can be written as a
ratio of these two polynomials but each
one has a closed form expression which
is a function of the reciprocals of the
roots and so when we take the ratio it
is the smallest root that dominates as K
goes to infinity okay so the bottom line
is we are actually converging we're with
our Fibonacci like construction to the
repelling
fixed point because we have only
repelling fixed points of the smallest
known
okay so that was magic number one so
let's see so the game plan was we wanted
to get close to a repelling fixed point
and then we wanted to use the Juliet sub
theorem to get everywhere else so what
did we do
well we kind of did get close to
repelling fixed point with the smallest
norm that's a check mark but we really
wanted to get here okay so this is some
kind of a tricky Bonacci tree like
construction that gets me here what
happens next well to be able to apply
the Julia set theorem I need the
neighborhood and I can now compute
backwards from a longer prime where in
the neighborhood they should have
originated from so that my univariate
map gets me to my lambda prime okay but
I got here and I need to leave from here
so what next well next we are going to
do two things
we are going to first generate a dance
set of points within this neighborhood
and then we are going to boost the dance
set to exponential precision so that
then we can leave and go to our lambda
prime okay so how do we create a dance
set well this is kind of switching gears
a lemma that has nothing to do with what
was happening before but will have
something to do with it soon if we have
a complex not real number Z with norms
more than one we claim that if you look
at polynomials with coefficients that
are non-negative integers they cover the
entire complex plane Dennis Lee and how
does this work
it turns out that the case when Z is a
rational angle it's a harder case so
that's the one that I'm going to draw
here so here is my Z inside so before it
looked like this was my Z and I'm going
to create polynomials with non-negative
integer
efficients and evaluate them at Z okay
so now if my angle at Z is rational and
I multiply Z with so I kind of get all
these points these are all integer
coefficient polynomials and then so that
means that I can get arbitrarily close
to zero on any of the days and then I
can use a coefficient in front of the
corresponding Z to the something term to
get completely bends on the array so now
I'm danced on the race and the last
thing is when I want to get a point
somewhere else I can write it as a
convex combination of points on the race
and I have to do the math with integer
coefficients but it works out when I
scale it up appropriately so no what do
we have we have all these polynomials
that are creating a dance set in the
complex plane what we want we want to
get absol hovering over here so we need
to connect the polynomials to our trees
somehow we need to be able to actually
construct these polynomials and so what
we are going to do we are going to first
of all observe that we need only a
finite number of polynomials to create
an epsilon covering of our neighborhood
of the fixed point epsilon covering
means at any point in the neighborhood
has to have somebody within business
epsilon in the covering okay and so if I
have this small set just just by packing
argument I need only a finite number of
polynomials evaluated at some Z to cover
this and I'm going to use multivariate
trees to generate these polynomials and
namely when I look at that at my
multivariate map and evaluate it close
to the fixed point I can use a Taylor
expansion and my deviation original from
the fixed point is going to be Z times
some of the previous deviations and so
what this means is we can look at
another
recursive construction where from these
deviations from the fixed point we are
getting this one so that brings us to
the construction of all of these
neighboring values around the fixed
point and now we claim that we can
actually for any polynomial we can
construct it using this kind of
recursive construction which because of
this connection corresponds to just a
tree okay okay so now what's happening
the last step and I know I'm out of time
something and very soon the last step is
now we have the epsilon covering within
the neighborhood of our fixed point we
now need to find this is the point that
would have eventually gotten me so under
prime
I have covering that is epsilon covering
but I really want this point and to be
close to it so I need to boost my
precision and how am I going to do it
I'm going to find a contracting map on
this neighborhood
and so if points were a distance
something now they're going to be a
distance some L smaller than one so its
contracting with a factor of L and so
when this is my target I can compute
backwards where I should have been with
this map and I go backwards until I have
a point and a desired precision in the
neighborhood and then I can just apply
the map forwards and because the
precision always keeps getting smaller
and smaller and smaller I will get close
to my target with exponential precision
that's roughly the intuition there is
some technicality needs to be worked out
but there's a problem the problem is
that the map that I have could escape so
what we can do instead we can create
several contracting maps that have the
effect of covering my neighborhood so
what this means
is that any point in my neighborhood has
a map that maps to it
and so that means that I always have an
option of staying within this
neighborhood and then I can use the idea
of doing the contracting maps to move me
from an absinthe covering to the target
point and now this is my last slide it's
a summary so what happened we start with
our lambda we build our Fibonacci trees
we get somewhere close 30 pounds a fixed
point then from that we use our
polynomials with integer coefficients to
create a dense neighborhood epsilon
hovering near the neighborhood of the
fixed point then we use the contracting
maps to get very close to the location
of the Lea we want to be in so that then
we can use another tree the univariate
map which corresponds to a be regular
complete tree to get closer along the
prime target value so putting this all
together we just get like a big tree but
not very big tree big enough and then we
can plug it in to the reduction and that
will give us the number of independent
set so this is the picture and well we
have some new results here but the
question is what is the ultimate it
[Applause]
so do you think that this loveliness so
having a cloth big graph and this people
not she type the recurrence proof do you
think that's crucial or could you go
about that well honestly that
construction that it actually works out
to be the claw free graph to me it's a
little bit like magic so I'm going to
look at Leslie Leslie has some better
intuition for why it actually should
work besides that it actually works out
no intuition now fortunately it's
beautiful yes so absolutely absolutely
he'll give you that density results with
no real no real roots gave me the
convergence so real roots allowed me to
express the activities that I'm building
up with the Fibonacci construction so
I'm building this lopsided trees right
and the real roots I can express the
activity down building with this
lopsided trees as a ratio of two
polynomials but it's meaningfully
defined only if the denominator is
nonzero so that's where the real roots
came in because I was plugging in London
there was a true complex value not on
the real line but it's sort of like also
it was crucial for the density thing
when you take and take converse
combination and you take non-negative
combination
the closure gives fourth Epis I think
those are different polynomials but but
for that resulted was important that Z
is not on the real life yes absolutely
absolutely absolutely absolutely though
I don't personally see a connection
between the Quaffle III real rootedness
yes you did need know that that number
is no real not to get the density yes
yes yes so there's a kind of like a
separate part of what do you do when you
have a number and the negative real line
but I was focusing on the on the truly
complex other hardness result which uses
so much of let's say chaos communiques
numbers I'm just curious this is the
first one which uses hoses can it's
another motivation where I need to start
do you know calculus and computer
science departments
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's not so difficult
yeah but then can you then connect them
to a tree construction I mean this this
will be one special yeah
justice almost like incidentally I don't
think that coincidentally citizens cross
witnesses
maybe I missed something while the final
hand is not happy because we went for a
problem of computing the number of
independent sets in the given graph page
the very first reduction yes yeah oh
it's just good for slides again behind
this I think she's referring to an older
result oh yeah yes this is this is
Sharpie heart also on the negative real
line yes yes yes
it's a copy-paste
inside the car do a statement you got a
pulse a fixpoint I mean so there are
points of the Julia set inside the
cardioid I believe but it's not a fixed
point so the question is how do you get
there
so demo question
so we break for lunch